[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
previously on model lifestyle
[Music]
spicy Korean food kimchi so we got some
spicy beef here and then we got some
pumpkin and egg
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Hey so I'm on the way to a meerkat cafe
yes a cafe where he can drink coffee but
you can also play with meerkats and I'm
gonna show you guys how that looks like
it's a little bit far away from where I
stay it's like 50 minutes so first we're
gonna take a bus and then we're gonna
take the subway
[Music]
they've have a lot of interesting cafes
here and so they have sheep cafes darker
these cat cafes music effects even
raccoon cafes
alright so here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
that's it
[Music]
all right hi hello I guess we have to
take our shoes off here yeah all right
[Music]
all right well the place is big ooh
[Music]
entrance fee
hey buddy they're very curious looking
at what is this thing but I'm hoping
here Wow they're scared very easily
check it out
hey buddy look
[Music]
okay check it out
this is the camera huh he's just the
camera check it out the camera
[Music]
okay oh they're so small I feel like I
want to step on them all right they sit
down let's see
hello oh there's a lot hey how did you
get in there oh hello
oh thank you so much all right so you
have to put this thing over what are
they doing right
that is not for you ear is not for you
hey buddy
[Music]
they can be like a statue looking he's
not moving
because anybody whoa this guy is closer
than I thought it would be oh that's a
weird
this is making himself home look at
these guys they're sleeping
yeah so tired shame whoop-whoop
[Music]
how did you get in here hey
[Music]
look how this guy's sitting he's like
the king you know she got these guys
taking my sock look he wasn't taking my
sock no no
[Music]
all right time to move on
okay say you guys so the meerkats let's
see what else they have here got a nice
wallaby oh man
is there foxes look at this Wow hey I've
never seen a white fox whoa oh my
goodness
I do think even this plays a little bit
too small for him shame
he just escaped from his cage Oh Oh
check it out they also have a raccoon
and
[Music]
look at it he's like kind of asking for
it I'm gonna stand from the side so you
guys can take it out
look
[Music]
check it out tikka
pooja schema is no hurry
[Music]
right and a very beautiful cat all right
that's it
so it was kind of fun it was interesting
when I walked in seeing the meerkats it
was a lot of fun and playing with them
as well but then as I saw the foxes I
was a little bit sad you know I'm not
judging them at all
I was just sad to see the foxes in the
cages and I didn't expect to feel that
way so I left a little bit early
[Music]
you
[Music]